hello freak [ __ ] see Tara is probably
very great at this point he's in his
seventies there's nothing wrong with
that what did you think about all this
Kathy Griffin [ __ ] she's ridiculous it's
[ __ ] insane
she needs friends why are you doing that
it's just it's a hundred percent
attention
what a [ __ ] call for a ten being
edgy she thought she was being edgy and
she probably was talking with the wrong
people and got the wrong idea in her
head and went with it and had no one
like you around ago what stuff soccer
are you talking about that's the
president and it's a person yeah human
yeah you can't you can't pretend you
want a murderer mices style and hold his
head up to the camera like a hostage
video that's [ __ ] crazy
I think it's just it's one of those
things where both both parties both
extreme left and extreme right are at
such a heightened version of what's
happening that people are becoming blind
to like logic yes but 100 percent logic
is like look what's gone yeah you would
[ __ ] never if somebody did that with
Obama the holy [ __ ] uh oh my god I mean
the [ __ ] world would stop spinning
there'd be so much chaos from that it
would be [ __ ] it would be an insane
thing to see that happen well look it's
just that's not any one solution like
that's not real so like holding up that
head is not a real solution like killing
anybody like that not not only that even
if it's like the worst person in the
world cutting their head off and holding
it up like that is [ __ ] barbaric we
wouldn't even want that from Osama bin
Laden if we found the video of Osama bin
Laden one of the seals held him down and
cut his head off and then held up the
camera we'd be [ __ ] extremely like
what are we doing why don't you just
kill them kill them think we're not them
should we're not we're not tortured and
we're not trying to terrorize all these
other people we're not going to become
what we're afraid of
right right and be that's what she's
doing by holding that head up you are
becoming what you were afraid of you're
becoming a monster your yours your dread
face you're not even emotionally
attached the fact you're holding up his
bloody head no what kind of nonsense
false imagery is this like you don't
really think that you don't really feel
that is it art like what is it is it art
that's what I am sure that's what the
argument from from Russ psych was it's
an artistic piece of wood
with a photographer who's but it's about
a real person it's not Medusa you just
thought like a dragon's head you're
holding up if it's you're crazy if it
your own head it's your own head you can
make a funny standing to make a
statement sure but it's like what are
you doing you're terrorizing that person
if you're that you have I know everybody
thinks that the president has to assume
a certain amount of mockery and I agree
that he does sure I agree everybody in
any position of power like that is going
to you're going to have people coming at
course but there's a difference between
that and advocating a brutal
assassination in terror video it has
head removal then a list yeah it's not
that's not no one's going to be
sympathetic towards your idea and in
fact you're going to empower the people
that are opposed to you because they're
going to think oh these people are these
crazy ideologues who want to like
literally promote the murder and torture
of someone cutting their head off the
whole thing is crazy but it's just it's
something that people do with they're
trying to get attention and they're
trying to entertain or trying to be
shocking they just it's a continuation
of trying to be in people's frontal lobe
you know it's like people in Hollywood
at some point just want to stay in
Hollywood and I feel like that's what
she does a lot I want to stay I want to
do something controversial on the [ __ ]
New Year's Eve host that she does or
whatever because you can stay in
Hollywood it's such a this great this
great director once told me that the sat
is never imagined if this is a this is
an actor and and as if we're the Sun and
and you know the Sun and the earth and
moving moving around one another just
like an actor in a spotlight it says if
the spotlight has on the actor at some
point but when it moves away if you
after tried to move towards it is when
it becomes sad when it shifted out of
your line of sight when when your work
and your progress has shifted as if your
time perhaps may be coming to a close as
far as it's worth when you are
continuing to search for it there's
nothing more desperate and more obvious
you think you can always see when
someone's hunting for it again in the
sad it looks it looks desperate it's
also contrary to the very reason people
like you in the first place but people
like you because you're doing things
they enjoy exactly doing good work
you're doing
good comedy make it a good movie
whatever the [ __ ] you do making a good
song that's why they like you they don't
want to like you because you're trying
to get attention
yeah or that you're trying to get people
to to just what I mean what is that I
mean what what what do you get out of
holding a head like what kind of
attacked you get like it but yeah well
yeah I don't go girl
okay we're with you [ __ ] kill em like
you're there's people that do think like
that and they could have easily been
right there might be left they could
have easily been right it's a it's a way
of thinking and you get that way of
thinking and then you program yourself
you get locked into this predetermined
pattern of behavior
[Applause]
[Music]